if you want to make money this weekend
basically starting with nothing what
would you do do i have a so i have no
capital you can have a hundred dollars
20 year old me scrappy
person you want me to make it a thousand
dollars thousand dollars a thousand
dollars i would uh i would make this
this is what i was thinking i would find
a uncle i don't look enough like santa
claus i would find a friend uncle
whoever that looks like santa claus i
have an uncle that's kind of chubby he's
got a white beard a real white beard and
he's santa claus in the malls i would
find somebody who could spin up a quick
app that allows me to pay five or ten
dollars a minute to have my kid facetime
with santa claus like i can say like hey
you're gonna fill out this little form
of what time you want me to call this
number and this is my kid's name and
then i'm gonna let my kid face time with
santa claus a real live santa claus and
pay 10 or 20 a minute and i think we
could we could do eight hours on
saturday and eight hours on sunday and
with one tweet
um you could make you could i'd find a
guy like somebody with influence and say
hey let's split the profits you make one
tweet for me i'll you know pay you half
the santa claus money that comes in and
i'd make a little app where you can pay
10 bucks a minute to have your kid face
time with santa claus because my kids
love santa claus but like they only get
to go see him once and they talk about
them and think about them every day so
if before bed one night they could call
him in facetime santa claus that'd be
pretty cool
that hits
yeah it definitely hits all someone's
gonna do that also that's loki apparent
hack
you're like tell sam what you want so i
can hear my friend i was talking to a
friend last night last night and he
pulled up this little app that is just a
recording it's a really low budget
recording but he's like my kids have
done this a hundred times and they don't
know this is not the real santa and he
pulls it up and it's like a app where
santa claus is like
clayton
what do you want for christmas
you know what i mean yeah but if you had
a real person that could ask them some
questions it would it would make your
kids so happy to be worth it to throw 50
bucks at that yeah if uh if somebody
builds it will you do it with us let's
do it somebody will definitely we gotta
hurry though because we gotta
get to
12 days of christmas right now no doing
on christmas eve is the big winner
like it's santa get ready to work
you're gonna need a lot of coffee yeah
listen we ain't got we got commentary
you just drink some water shut up sit
down talk to the kids be quiet
no but but i think that
people are literally saying uh okay you
santa schillers
or people have a problem with everything
i don't think you can patent that i
think i think that would bring kids joy
so they would of course and some santa
that has to sit in them all day to earn
a couple hundred bucks could earn a
couple thousand bucks damn it my idea
was to go caddy for the weekend
i love that stuff too i mean your sounds
that's the easy one much more lucrative
if you if you don't have the ability to
make the app or network to to spin it up
it'd be really hard to get traction so
in that case i would i'd hang christmas
lights or go do some powerful fall
cleanup fall cleanup is big people have
leaves all over the lawn i'd get rid of
them yeah fall cleanup i feel like it's
like a super easy just uh effort base
like i love the effort-based ones where
it's like look dude grab a rake shut up
and start raking right yeah and like i
mean a thousand dollars a thousand
dollars is right in that realm of like
if you do physical labor for the weekend
you can do that you're gonna do it
hanging christmas lights is a phenomenal
a growing i don't say it's a phenomenal
business but it's a growing business i
mean there are wealthy neighborhoods in
athens which is a
small town where every single house has
spent five grand to have them come in
and people come in and put up a little
tree in the front lawn and put like it's
not much that you pay his five grand to
get christmas lights five thousand
dollars to hang christmas lights i feel
like that's a lot that's awesome
put it up and then take it back down and
have the lights for next year and you
storm in my storage unit
yeah i mean if you really think about it
like somebody's paying five thousand
dollars to get their christmas lights
hung up right you could run through a
neighborhood you know
let's say a family they're both lawyers
they both make 300 grand a year
is it really wise to get up on a ladder
and try to figure out hanging up
christmas lights and risk going to the
orthopedic surgeon with a messed up back
like if you want your house to look
really nice for a whole month like it's
it's worth it right
yeah
same thing as the lawn almost and then
there's the then there's these like the
botanical gardens at uga i took my kids
there and and they spent like 750 000 to
bring a company into outfit the entire
botanical gardens full of christmas
lights and it's an awesome spectacle
like it was great to take the kids it
was worth the 15 entry fee but some
company got contracted for 750 grand to
set up a ton of christmas lights in
about a five acre uh garden yes someone
in the chat said they just charged
someone 12 000 to hang up lights on a
restaurant in new york
now we're talking